all das sieht mein kopf schon wieder
riesig aus hallo leute ich sie teure mal
waren und willkommen zu einem neuen
video und heute machen wir uns die
fingernägel die haben ist auch echt
nötig ich weiß auch nicht wie menschen
dauerhaft saubere fingernägel haben
könnt ich kann es einfach
obwohl ich sie mir ständig sauber mache
sind sie dann doch mal dreckig wenn wir
auf instagram volk weise sich in letzter
zeit katjas und queens bild parodiert
habe aber noch
also das war aus voller liebe und ich
danke euch wie ganzen komplimente ich
glaube an dieser stelle sagen wenn ihm
ein kompliment macht müsst ihr die
andere person nicht in dem kompliment
dessen also ich bin nicht schöner sein
als wenn ihr sagt menschen also die sich
so tolles oder mensch dein buch ist wie
ein frisch gepflügt dafür sehe ich dann
kann ich das toll aber dann müsst ihr
nicht sagen ja und katja oder schrien
die sieht daneben ja gar nicht so gut
aus jeder sieht aus wie er aussieht wenn
man ein bisschen mehr plastik und
kooperation markt und findet man es auch
schön und ich finde das sind zwei ganz
tolle frauen und deswegen haben sie mich
inspiriert dieses video zu drehen und
zwar ist mir dabei aufgefallen was für
mörder fingernägel die beiden haben ich
weiß nicht wie sie mit diesen nägeln den
alltag bewältigen können wenn ich ins
nagelstudio g oder hier mir auch schon
mal selber die nägel gemacht habe traue
ich mich nicht länger als sieben so so
so wild und da ich mit dem make up geben
schon mega gut dabei bin und mich extrem
durch schminke liebe im letzten video
herausgefunden haben dachte ich warum
versuche ich das auch nicht mal mit den
nägeln vielleicht gefällt mir dass er
total und vielleicht kann ich ja auch
einige dinge dafür eingekauft dass nägel
game wird heute strom sein
immer wenn ich im prettiner shirt bin
und barren kaufen will ende ich mit so
einer auswahl der staatsbahn sollte hier
habe ich so runde weiße steine dann
haben wir auch noch so einhorn artige
und weiße steine dann haben wir auch mal
ganz klar sich ist uns sehr über eine
ornamente doch mehr einholen
der bund was ich mega cool fahren so
dunkle glitzersteinchen ja ich will dass
die am ende so richtig extrem sind ich
weiß nicht ob man sich selber so lange
fingernägel machen kann oder ob das
daran scheitern wird dass ich meine
linke hand mache und dann mit der
rechten schon gar nicht mehr klarkommen
werden es herausfinden und konfekt ich
hab schon mal dieses wieder angefangen
zu drehen und mein tipp kleber war
eingetrocknet also musste ich neuen tipp
lieber kaufen kann die ganze sei ich bin
halt wir beginnen damit dass wir unsere
finger so an rauen tut mir so leid ich
bin trage laut so das ist meine
professionelle vorbereitung denn wickle
mich ready zu seinem youtube-channel
firma immer so phasen es gibt zu fahren
aber ich nur kochen und eine phase da
will ich nur gute sachen machen unsere
finger sind jetzt rauer kommen sitzen
profis um den zob wir brauchen natürlich
unsere lampe brauche das hirn trauma
stift jetzt malen wir uns die finger an
weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht was der stift
macht das auf der rechten bahn ist es
schon so viel komplizierter das ist so
ein tipp mit dem wir jetzt arbeiten dem
müssen wir jetzt so auf unseren finger
kleben kann mich mal bitte jemand auf
halten und sagen das ist schlechte idee
ist also man kann ich schon sagen ich
bin under pressure meine ich muss jetzt
lange dinge an meine finger kleben das
wird schon war
der kleber funktioniert aber ich habe
mir einen tropfen pro nageln jetzt schon
so viel zu viel drauf gemacht
wenn man den halt falsch drauf klebt das
schon alles verkackt einfach ne das ist
auf jeden fall zu wenig um alle so krass
lang lassen wir die auf jeden fall nicht
um ein gold ich sehe mich noch nicht wie
das auf die andere seite kleben kann
aber wir werden schon seiner
entschuldigung er könnte wieder den
manager sprechen oder sowas
superpraktisch nun durch die haare zu
gehen sollte ich die vielleicht noch mal
schon mal auf die richtige länge kürzen
bevor ich die anderen ja wir haben ein
kürzungs gerät und gibt wer das sollte
ab auch zur nächsten hand und auf den
der schießt fest kann nicht greifen
frag mich war die erste person sich
gedacht hat dass sie sich die
fingernägel verlängern möchte und dann
irgendwas erfunden hat und sie auf die
nägel geklebt hat so leute und das war's
mit meinem tutorial so macht ihr euch
fingernägel wie shirin katja dachtet ihr
jetzt geht es erst los
jetzt sind wir absolut gehandicapt in
unserer bewegung ich habe das gefühl
nichts mehr greifen zu können
ich fühle mich auch extrem fancy als
nächsten schritt schleifen wir es klingt
auch wie so ein handwerker nun machen
wir unsere erste geschichte
das ist unser grundidee was wir jetzt
brauchen auch so wenn man kann dich
jetzt gehen jetzt muss ich mich in
diesem thema benutzen so paar mal
benutzt
woher ich das spannend ist es gut auch
mal wenn ihr die lampen macht darf
erkundigen nicht in der nähe sein weil
sonst wird das alles fest in der schale
es ist so schwer mit langen fingernägeln
so die hat muss jetzt in die lampe es
wird heiß
unangenehm unangenehm ich habe das
schwert das hat man aber auch mit meinem
neuen studios sieht sich nur weil ich in
drei filmen
jetzt beginnt erst der richtige spaß
denn ich muss mit meiner rechten hand
meine linke anmalen glaub ich hab diese
nagel tipps zu weit nach hinten geklebt
jetzt definitiv weiter vorne lassen
sollen das war wahrscheinlich auch mein
erster fehler beim verein ausgeht dann
ist das schlimm manche würden sagen es
sieht schlecht aus
ich würde sagen es sieht schlimmer aus
ich schlafe jetzt mal alle fingernägel
zurecht und dann sehen uns gleich wieder
ich habe jetzt spitze fingernägel wenn
wir drei millionen schichten von ultra
bohnen drauf gemacht haben einmal den
pinsel reinigen und an die tür gehen
jetzt brauchen wir fiberglas gehen ich
sag das auch so als ob das irgendwie
ging wer jetzt noch mit fiberglas gehe
ich habe keine ahnung ob das wirklich
stimmt dabei sind als ob man versuchen
würde zuckerguss aufzutragen ja es fühlt
sich an wie zuckerguss das tue ich mir
schon wieder an
warum tue ich mir solche sachen an
euro pfand nummer zwei wir sehen uns
gleich wieder wenn ich die farbe darauf
mache mein gott ich weiß es sieht nicht
schön aus aber da ist ja auch noch keine
farbe drauf ich bin nur stolz darauf
dass ich relativ stabile lange
fingernägel habe aber ganz ehrlich ich
hasse es jetzt schon jetzt machen wir
noch einmal sauber und staub und fett
und allen möglichen befreien
ich habe eine neue farben gekauft wet
look newsweek
so sieht die farbe aus nun stellen wir
uns der allerwichtigsten frage wie
schnell dann haben wir noch nicht genug
das brauchen wir auch wenn wir wollen
diese nägel wenn die schon solang sind
wenn die voll mit steine geklebt das
gilt sieht halt normal aus und dann
parallel pastell fernen dieser ton
erinnert mich am meisten an schienen
katja das sieht einfach aus wie kaugummi
und will jetzt einfach so kuckuck des
ist die farbe will nicht mehr dass da
nur so lange mich vergessen ist jedes
mal wieder weg streamen
es dauert natürlich eine zweite schicht
nicht vergessen
ich frag mich wie ich später auf
toilette gehen soll jetzt sind wir mit
bernd hamm verhandelt jetzt müssen wir
nur noch die rechte macht
ich melde mich gleich zurück wenn beide
finger diesen tollen pinken farbton
haben und wie mit den steinchen
weitermachen können das sind
david cash money der trommel kleinen
steinchen wenn ich die paarung aufträge
natürlich packung aufmachen gibt es zu
lange nägel das sind die glitzersteine
ich denke ich werde einfach alle
brauchen gab sogar ein neues gerät
gekauft
ich wusste nicht was ist kann oh mein
gott das sieht aus wie eine medien film
und kann ich dann so funktioniert das
doch okay wir versuchen wir den ersten
stein draufzukleben bussen dieser
klebebänder nail art bügelbrett einmal
so kleben
eisenstein damit oben
na komm jetzt jetzt jetzt tu was für
dein geld greifen den stein habe ich
hier so kleine silberne dinge kitschig
kann diese scheiße nicht auf ich werde
hier noch safe zwei stunden sitzen jetzt
mehr die karneval so machen sollen an
karneval würde keiner eine frage stellen
ich mache jetzt noch neun weitere finger
und dann zeige ich euch am ende wie
meine jerry buss der finger
mein daumen hat richtig gewicht zwei
fingern die gefährlichen dann zeige ich
euch das ergebnis
ich mache den allerletzten stein seit
sechs stunden sitze ich hier machen wir
meine fingernägel wo man das ist der
letzte stein
oh mein gott ist ein gutes gefühl ich
sitze hier wirklich seit sechs stunden
ich kann aber dass harry potter werbung
weiterhören nehmen wir den glacis klima
5000 und mache jetzt meine fingernägel
brav tut mir leid dass ich euch nicht so
viel vom prozess gezeigt habe wie man
diese finger nie gemacht aber ich muss
ehrlich sagen das war super bowl ring
das sind sie die sind so lang muss aber
sagen auch wenn ich das sonst nicht so
tragen würden ich find dich schon echt
hübsch oh mein gott jetzt noch mit
diesem rosa handy schreiben geht schon
mal nicht mehr die ganze aber meine
fingernägel anschauen einfach actually
insane es einfach kunstwerke da gebaut
hast ein bisschen sailer und vibes auch
macht des mondes
ja leute was ist dieses video aber jetzt
bin ich auf jeden fall mein ziel näher
so wie shirin oder kaka zu werden wenn
ich das video nenne ich teste muss hier
jetzt ein test machen mein letzter test
wie popelt mal mit den nägeln sehr gut
gute nacht leute bis zum nächsten video
wäsche machen mit nägeln an händen
greifen euch zugegriffen